urna en mano estos voluntarios están
haciendo la ronda Indonesia
estamos aquí para el referéndum ahora la
puerta Por favor Ya les dejo entrar el
voto puerta a puertas por seguridad dice
solo hay una pregunta en la papeleta
está usted a favor de unirse a la
federación rusa
es importante nos hemos preguntado
cuando nos uniremos a Rusia nuestras
vías eran mucho más tranquilas con urnas
transparentes y sin sobres los votos de
las personas están a la vista los
colegios electorales improvisados son
una de las pocas cosas que quedan en pie
Mario Paul devastada por los bombardeos
rusos los autodenominados referendos se
celebran en las regiones separatistas de
doniesk y así como en las zonas ocupadas
de gerson y saporigia en el sur estas
personas huyeron de la violencia en
gerson y ahora están desplazadas dicen
que no quieren formar parte de Rusia
Cómo puedes arrancar ilegalmente una
parte de Ucrania venir a casa de otros y
hacer lo que les plazca no lo apoyo
estoy en contra del referéndum creo que
mi ciudad y mi región pertenecen
plenamente Ucrania
las votaciones tras la reconquista por
parte de Ucrania de vastas franjas de
territorio ocupado por Rusia han sido
calificadas como una farsa por kiev y
occidente los expertos dicen que
permitirán a Moscú reclamar ilegalmente
regiones ocupadas de Ucrania como
propias y podrían llevar al kremlin a
afirmar que su territorio está siendo
atacado por las armas occidentales
suministradas a kiev lo que podría
intensificar la guerra